[Music]
all right uh thanks so much for the kind
introduction and yeah let's get started
uh and let's talk about about llm
applications for a
bit all right cool so basically the uh
goal of this talk for me is for you to
take away a couple of things right so
first in the first like 15 to 20 minutes
of the talk I want to talk about the
basics of uh large language models not
like the
internals um or how they work but uh
basically how to uh think about them uh
from a practitioner point of view and
how to build with them right so that
might include uh which Which models to
choose there's a lot of them um how to
access them right because there's also
many options and and and what challenges
we faced in production and and what we
learned right uh we did a lot of
experiments in last couple of months and
gain some insights and along the way I
also want to teach you about uh uh Ray
uh and how to scale workloads with it
right and uh the second part of the
presentation is about applications we
build uh in practice and I'm just going
to show you or like demo these uh these
these applications and then point you to
to a more in-depth treatment uh later on
like like if if you're interested in
building something like that you can
just um copycat what we did and and
build your own stuff right so that
includes a QA B and and some GitHub B
that comments on your poll requests okay
and we see more about that
later okay cool so uh on a very
simplistic high level um large language
models are these very expensive uh black
boxes into which you put some some
prompt some text uh as input and
hopefully outome some useful text right
something that that helps you with your
your use case um and one thing that that
is absolutely clear is uh not only are
they they hard to understand in terms of
you know interpretability like like how
they how they actually work Al although
we make some progress uh on that front
as well but they're also um very hard to
to evaluate um depending on on what use
case you have in mind right uh it's not
always clear in the in the end to to say
is that really like like a good a good
answer or can I expect something more
from the system
okay um and something that we see in in
the last couple of months uh
predominantly with the uh close Source
models like the commercial models uh
we're going multimodal right so uh we're
moving from llms to lmm uh large
multimodel models which take um um more
um um modalities as as input and
potentially is output not necessarily at
the same time um but uh in some
combination or form right so so there
are models specialized on code uh that
you can ask for code and it outputs code
or you you have models that you uh
prompt with uh let's say um images and
text and it outputs uh text as well or
like like like images right and and
hopefully like in the next couple of
months we'll see uh more development on
the open source models as well uh
catching up with that uh kind of picture
here all right uh something that's also
quite uh interesting and important is uh
how language models interact with uh
different systems and parts of the
ecosystem right so uh you can you can
describe this as as tool use um uh if
you if you regularly use uh for instance
Chet GPT you know that it's capable of
browsing with ping in this particular
intense instance or that it can uh
execute code or do some Advanced uh data
analytics or interact with some some
some apis in the background uh some
plugin system of
sorts and uh another thing that's that's
very important uh and that also kind of
kind of dampens some of the uh the bad
uh effects that you see with uh wrong
outcomes and hallucinations in in
language models is uh data augmentation
specifically uh retrieval retrieval
augmented uh generation which we talk
about uh a bit more uh in a couple of
slides to kind of help improve enrich
the context of your input prompts to uh
improve the output of your uh the F
Fidelity of your models
okay all right and then the question is
uh should you train these these models
yourself um and of course like the if
you know a bit more about that uh if we
talk like about the first stage of
training uh pre-training your your own
uh Foundation model uh that is certainly
not possible unless you work for for
like a a really big uh Company open a
Google uh and Co but um if you want to F
tune uh an existing model to your
specific use case uh may it be a very
simple uh supervised fine-tuning or some
some form of uh re reinforcement
learning through human feedback that is
uh certainly doable and uh it kind of
depends on what use case you have if
that makes sense and if it's feasible
right and uh for the uh experts among
you uh if you if you know what that is
we have a very uh in-depth treatment
about uh when to use full parameter
training versus Laura um and I encourage
you to to check out this blog post it's
it's very uh detailed and tells you uh
when to do kind of which type of fine
tuning all
right so assuming zooming out even even
more like if you incorporate all of that
U multimodality tool use um all of that
uh like what we really want from from
language models in the future is them
being not just you know simple chat Bots
and chat interfaces but truly agents
that act autonomously and do tasks on
their own by sitting at the center
basically as the CPU if you
uh interacting with users interacting
with code interacting with apis and so
on right and there's a really nice blog
post not not written by us but I I like
that very much um it's called the rise
of the AI engineer that I want to point
you to um this this is a really nice uh
kind of role description of uh of a new
role that's emerging that's going Beyond
just uh being a prompt engineer or terms
like that you you hear sometimes but
really someone who's who's working on
all parts or some parts of the equation
for for building uh agents
right um yeah and I think the the the
upshot in some ways um also moving into
the demo section soon is um you should
think about llms as kind of building
blocks that you as Engineers or
scientists data scientists engineers uh
can can use as part of like the bigger
picture like and introduce them to your
toolbox and do cool stuff with them
right there's they're no no experts yet
um okay cool of course there's the the
kind of the 8 800 pound gorilla in the
room like uh open AI dominates or has
been dominating the the discussion uh
especially as of late and they're making
a lot of money commercially but but also
a lot of uh um ground um scientifically
when it comes to building Cutting Edge
uh closed Source uh language models
right and uh what you see on the left
since we're at Pi data um this is kind
of the the standard way you would
interact with open AI if you wanted to
to get some uh some answer from their
their chat system right so they they
have a chat completion API in which you
specify the model in this case uh GPT
3.5 T turbo uh which is kind of their
second best uh model available for for
Pure uh language models and uh you
specify what what it has to do and you
give it some prompt and it outputs uh
something right so this is the the basic
way of interacting with uh with open as
a as a python
developer uh one of many of
course all right uh quickly uh changing
gears here um so kind of kind of a
little uh known fact uh the the company
I work for uh any scale builds the
software called Ray which is uh used for
Distributing uh python workflows uh
specifically for machine learn for
machine learning uh and other workloads
that need more flexibility than than
other systems allow and uh chat GPT and
all the other large models at scale at
openi and Uther and coher for that
matter as well have been trained on Ray
as the infrastructure layer uh down
below right and um it's a good idea to
to consider and look at uh at Ray
because you know uh I don't think I have
to to convince you as a as a pat crowd
that python is everywhere but uh also
machine learning is is is growing as a
as a field um and we see that uh scaling
more and more is is becoming a NE
necessity right so you cannot really get
around uh scaling to to to multiple
machines even if you have like really
beefy machines uh if you're using them
in the cloud it's usually at some point
if you're doing something non-trivial
with uh larger models uh you have to you
have to scale out at some point not just
for training also for inference
right um all right and I this is this is
by no means like like a product pitch
but I just want to mention that any
scale as the company behind uh behind
Ray is you can think of it as as like a
like a hosted Ray uh solution right and
it's trusted by by many interest
industry uh partners that you see listed
here all right uh so in a bit more depth
uh not really introducing too much here
what is what is Ray right uh I already
mentioned that it's it's kind of a
flexible distributed distributed python
uh system right so you can uh scale out
your your workloads from your laptop to
a cluster of computers uh but you could
also for instance use it on just your
laptop to to use it as a drop-in
replacement for multiprocessing or
something like that right if you have
something that's uh embarrassingly
parallel to to uh to to um parallelize
on your laptop you can do that
efficiently uh with uh Ray even just on
your laptop because python has some uh
limitations
uh with uh multi fading and so on right
um so on the low level um Ray is a
distributed uh compute engine right so
it has a distributed Schuler it can kind
of kind of schedule and execute tasks
and uh one layer on top of that you have
a very elegant and I'm going to show you
this in in one quick example on the next
slide a very elegant uh core API and Ray
core basically has Primitives that allow
you to scale python functions to uh Ray
tasks and python classes uh to Ray
actors right so there's there's a COR
one to one correspond correspondence
between kind of uh stateless structures
and functions and stateful structures in
in in actors right so if you if you want
to do anything that you want to scale
out you basically just put like like a
decorator uh on top of your python
function or your your your class and
you're more or less ready to scale out
uh given that your cluster is set up
properly all right and um on top of that
basic Ray cor layer we have a suit of
really uh interesting libraries uh for
model training supports pie torch
supports tensorflow uh all the good
stuff uh we do um hyperparameter
optimization with Ray tune it supports
optuna um hypert and and many other
libraries uh serving model models with
fast API for instance and and all of
that is kind of batteries included to to
scale out on your cluster right um okay
cool right so so here's a quick example
I I think I indicated that uh already on
the on the last uh slide but if you have
any function called f in in uh in Python
that takes two parameters A and B and it
just returns to sum right might make
sense for Strings or uh numbers
um then basically you can you can
decorate that function with a ray.
remote decorator and give it some
optional kind of scaling configuration
that tells it how to scale out the
individual tasks and uh if you then call
instead of just you know F of one and
two which would return three locally if
you uh put f. remote one two it will
would be uh executed on a cluster right
um and if you do that with let's say a
list comprehension right uh these
individual tasks would would be able to
to scale that out on on several machines
and if you have a a workload that
requires uh scaling out which this one
obviously isn't uh but if you do uh this
this would all be taken care of for you
all
right um yeah and you see a lot of these
these Integrations that I mentioned in
the uh in the
bottom cool um quickly about me uh
thanks again for for the introduction so
but I'm I'm doing um engineering at any
scale I'm working in the rapid iteration
team which is responsible for kind of
building uh and scaling and
productionizing uh llm uh applications
at at any scale and making the services
that we buildt internally available for
for everyone um also teaching data
science and uh I'm a book author right
and I think maybe some of you have
already seen that I brought a couple of
uh copies like 25 copies or so there at
the uh Booth uh next door if you already
got your copy and you didn't come to say
hi please find me I can sign your copy
if you if you want to there's still a
couple of left couple of books left um
just just go find me after the talk I
can I can give you a free copy right if
that appeals to you uh also something
you should know is that the book is
basically free online right so you if
you would just want to uh have the pdf
version and you're willing to give your
sacred email address you can get it for
free as well right um cool and then the
last Point uh which is kind of important
and which which kind of brings me here
uh to Pi data um I've been uh
contributing to to uh the python
ecosystem a lot uh since basically 2014
I think I've been only doing open source
work so kind of GitHub is is the place I
live more or less and uh yeah so I I
started with caras intensif flow um I've
been uh maintaining hyper opt uh for a
while and uh I'm now like a core uh
contribute to Ray so if you have any any
questions or want to want to talk uh to
me about these any any of these logos
you see uh or want to help maintain any
of these projects uh please uh approach
me
afterwards all right cool um right so
there's not just chat GPT right there's
there's other models as well from from
other companies uh producing close
Source models but we also have a growing
ecosystem a whole zoo really
of Open Source models that um that are
trying to to catch up with the uh close
Source uh versions and uh the one model
family that is really considered
strongest right now is the Llama 2
family from from meta um which kind of
uh tops out all the leaderboards of the
non-commercial uh models right uh but
there's there's other models that are uh
similar in strength like like Falcon and
and and others right and another the
question becomes uh if I don't want to
use openi for whatever reason or I want
to try something else how can I access
other models and and of course there are
few you know canonical candidates like
like hugging phase uh fireworks AI has
has a really nice integration for uh
open source models as well there are
many many others right so I don't want
to act as if this this list is complete
cool all right now what um remember this
like this is this is the openi python
client this is how you interact with uh
with open AI right if you look closely
um skipping to the next
slide if I just replace the API key uh
from an openi API key to an any scale
API key and they changed the model from
um from uh GPT 3.5 turbo to Llama
270b Or 13B or 7B or the code llama
model uh I can basically do the exact
same thing so we're basically hijacking
the open AI uh API you don't even need
to install in the library right so you
you just need to sign up for instance
with uh with any scale uh some other
competitors do something uh similar
right it's it's very common to to kind
of Clone the open open AI API or
integrate with them and support um a
different suit of models right and so um
what I'm saying is that um if you if you
look into the market and you you you
take a look around you see that there
are other models available that you can
use kind of in the same way right and um
right uh any scale is not uh special in
that sense but I I just want to point
out that this is a viable uh solution
here that is also quite uh cheap and
fast
right um all right cool so now the
question really becomes like when do you
need which model right and it kind of
depends on your use case I think I
mentioned this before in the beginning
um so for instance uh we figured out and
you can you can read the blog post about
that on the on the Anis blog um we found
out that llama 2 is absolutely
sufficient for for text summarization so
you you don't need gp4 right it's also
better than uh 3.5 tber for for some
reason um they they they are kind of
kind of the most comparable so llama 7db
and and GPT 3.5 turbo are quite similar
in many respects but uh llama 2 keep it
keep it in mind is kind of 30 times
cheaper than G before and much faster
right so if you have a very restricted
and limited use case um going for an
open source model might actually make
sense right uh another use case that is
not by us but that I found kind of
appealing is um if you want to do some
some interesting use case like like re
recipe classification where you have
some some online resource of of recipes
and it's free text right so that can be
handled by a by language model and you
want to classify which you know which
type which type of uh of of recipe it is
right um You can do that with a language
model you can just say here's the recipe
in text form give me a classification
what is it right is it is it a desert or
what if you if you do that on the nose
with gbd4 you're you're down like 23k
right so that's that's quite a lot of
money but if you find youe a llama model
which which you can do in in a couple of
minutes basically uh cost the whole
thing of uh this this whole
classification task costs 20 bucks right
so so this becomes affordable all of a
sudden and of course I don't know which
which kinds of use cases you have and
I'm definitely not claiming that uh like
open source models can always help you
uh but uh you'd be surprised if you get
your hands dirty and Tres try some of
the uh smaller open source models uh how
they can can actually compete in some uh
use cases all right so of course there
there's there's a couple of factors that
you have to keep in mind when you when
you look at Which models to pick right
uh obviously this this list goes goes on
forever but uh quality speed cost are
basically the big
ones all right um cool so when to find
tune models um this this this might not
be super super interesting uh to to to
those of you who who have never done any
fine tuning task on on language models
but this is kind kind of a current Trend
uh people do it more and more right and
um we did like this this really cute
experiment where we trained we
fine-tuned uh a uh a Lama model on
basically a corpus of text that
incorporated um uh the The Works of
Shakespeare right and we tried to make
Romeo Bob yeah as you all know Bob Bob
and Juliet yeah and so we we we fine
tune we we kept fine tuning again and
again and we tried to change the fact
that like the main character's name is
not Romeo but Bob it doesn't work right
the the language model refuses to to
change kind of its its ground uh base
right so if if something is not uh
grounded in the model and you want to
change that you want to change the facts
it's not possible but if you want to
change the presentation and what the
model should be focusing on what it
should be outputting what uh what format
it should be outputting what aspect it
should be focusing on that is very much
possible right and we did some some
other uh fine fine tuning uh case
studies in which we um we showed that
you can you can easily uh generate SQL
queries to to sufficient um equality
with uh fine tun Lama models and and
Tackle grade school math which I think
is is
cool all right um yeah and now let's
move over over to some some demos like
um like I said the the main purpose is
not to to give you like like a a drill
down into what exactly happened if if
you want to clone like like what I do uh
you you can you can read it after the
talk uh just to give you an impression
of what is possible with models like
that all right so the first application
I want to talk about is uh Dr document
uh document is basically an open source
uh GitHub bot uh on the first link if
you if you want to check that out you
find basically a link to to GitHub and
you can just uh single click deploy that
bot on your own open source project and
then whenever you open a poll request it
will basically critique what you wrote
in the poll request right so this is
this is kind of cool and I also put up
an example PR but we will see a video of
documentor in in practice right um
cool and one thing I I want to point out
is that the the fast responses we get
from documentor are due to Ray because
in instead of just asking a language
model once we basically scale out uh
several requests for all the files we
have in parallel and get responses um
from each of these models uh at the same
time so basically by by Distributing um
the whole thing we reduce wall clock
time for larger P requests right so this
is this is kind of
cool so now hopefully that
starts let me introduce you to document
a new GitHub bot deployed to improve the
writing in your pro requests this bot is
powered by N scale services and N scale
endpoints in particular and if you want
to check out the source code uh click
the link below to
get all right let's say we have a new po
request that changes two text files one
read me uh just markdown and one python
file that has a do string but both files
are kind of flawed have grammar mistakes
and spelling errors all right let's
create this pull request and once we do
you will see that within a second or so
a documentor will actually respond by
breing you and telling you how to use it
the main command is document run and if
we paste this command into a new um
command uh the Bob will be triggered and
we will get a response soon while this
command is running let me tell you about
about how uh documentary actually works
so technically speaking it is a GitHub
app that needs to be installed on your
GitHub rapo and once you ad mention the
bot uh it will get triggered and send a
web hook request to our backend service
which is uh an any scale service
instance which will uh in turn query any
scale endpoints in this case a llama 70b
uh large language model and this will
respond with improvements for your
documentation and the NC will then uh
Leverage The GitHub API to write back a
command on your P request all right
let's see how we how we did and you will
see that documenter finished analyzing
the pr and it commented on the readme
and on the test file it has some
detailed detailed instructions and
usually it finds all the grammar and
spelling mistakes and it also gives you
uh improvements on on how to do that
like for instance here the parameters
for your for your doct string could be
could be added all right
right so how does it work in the
background uh instead of sending all the
request data for the diff in your P
request uh to one uh large language
model which can be quite a lot of work
uh we split up the work with a ray task
and send uh the content for each file in
our case uh just two files but could be
much more in practice uh to an
individual uh large language model call
all right uh this is this is done with r
right and how do we know that it's
actually any good um this is difficult
but the way we approach it is we first
ask gp4 to generate some flawed
sentences uh like uh minor short
sentences or uh or some paragraphs and
then we ask documentary to improve it
after which gp4 has to judge the results
of that and if both of these systems
document and gp4 agree largely uh we
consider this a good result and so far
in our evaluation we've seen that a
document actually gives G quite solid
and and and decent results and of course
systems like these can always be
improved but we're quite happy with uh
what the bot can do right
now all right cool uh yeah apologies I
had to pre-record things because I I did
not uh uh the guys did not want me to
give the demo today but uh yeah anyway
that that's document I hope you like
that um if you want to do something
something similar like it doesn't have
to be uh about that comments on your
poll request could be could be anything
else right um You can you can basically
just clone this this blueprint from us
from us and and do something else right
and the second application I want to
show you real quickly is and uh ask ask
me anything bought for for the ray
documentation and I think you've seen
that or like like most of you might have
seen that this is popping up everywhere
left and right so if you go on any
technical documentation uh these days
usually in the right uh right hand
corner you see like like a button as ask
AI and then you can interact with uh the
website right and ask questions about uh
the content and um the cool thing is
that we we basically build something
like that end to endend um uh by by
ourselves and we we documented the
process so that you can do the same
right um
cool right there's another much quicker
video which I have to walk you through
so this is the ray documentation and if
you click the button in the the uh in
the right
and you ask a question like give me a
aray core code example it will then
proceed to stream the response and uh
dynamically render the python code for
you and as you will see in a second like
inline inline code is also handled and
uh we also provide sources to the files
in which you find the the answer or
stuff that you might be interested in
right and so yeah basically that's
that's already kind of kind of the whole
demo but uh just want to point out again
that uh like like this whole system has
been trained uh by us so we basically
scraped our own documentation uh chunked
it accordingly um I should go to the
next slide we we chunked the docks
accordingly uh split it up put it into a
vector database um for that you need to
create some embeddings can't really talk
about that in in detail here um and once
once you have these embeddings you can
basically query um your your database
for for uh for similar similarity so if
somebody ask asks a question about your
documentation you pick up from your
database the most similar content
whatever that might mean and enrich the
context of your language model with uh
the stuff you have from the database
including the sources the links and and
then you you crunch through your your um
your model and uh and get a good uh
response right and we also build the
front end for it so it's it's really
fully end to end right and one thing uh
I want to mention at the very uh end is
that we also have something that's kind
of nice uh which is a so-called model
router uh which you see in in the right
uh because we we kind of trained a
classifier to uh to capture whether um
an open source weaker model but uh you
know faster and not as expensive would
be capable of handling the question
right so if it's not uh too technical of
a question or or Too Too Deep of of a
question in terms of knowledge base you
can defer um the request to an open
source model and otherwise you can use
gb4 right so and this this this kind of
smart router system is something that we
we dive into more and more because I I
think it's very uh useful and instead of
having like like a fully trained
supervised classifier you can also have
like a just a text file that you provide
to yet another uh language model and
this language model basically decides
which one should answer right and so
there's there's a lot of really cool
things that you can do if you if you
want to save some time or some money all
right all right that's pretty much it uh
thanks so much and yeah any
[Applause]
questions
thank you um yeah very interesting
presentation the Q&A model that you just
showed um I assume that it did work with
fine tuning probably or not no okay so
so it was a completely different
approach because so maybe you can
explain that further because I'm I'm
also looking for a Q&A do I have to F
tune or do I have to do some prompt
engineering what is
the way what is the way to go there I
think you can do both but like the the
standard approach for tackling such
problems is basically to um to go ahead
and do like a like a retrieval augmented
generation Playbook right this is
basically what I'm outlining here so
basically you you take your your data
sources and you you chunk it up in some
way right could be sentences for
instance if it makes sense like if it's
if it's purely uh purely uh text based
uh splitting by sentences might make
sense but if you have code like several
lines of code might uh belong to each
other so to speak so it it kind of
depends on your strategy right and you
you can basically ask your system also
to to uh to optimize that part right so
we we did some some hyperparameter
optimization on the chunking strategy
right this this this is a bit going
going a bit far but uh you can
definitely do that and once you have
that you you embed these uh sentences
right and then you have this this vector
vector database with uh with embeddings
of your core content that you want to
enrich your prompts with right so but
this is not prompt Engineering in a in a
manual way but it's like like a like
like an automated retrieval of relevant
context and the way this is done is um
that's why we use uh Vector databases by
the way like like if you check out this
this blog post it's it's uh like like a
50-minute read or something like that so
it really walks you through every single
step and you can reproduce it at home
basically right um but the the reason
you use Vector databases is because they
have this this really nice property of
having uh efficient lookup right because
uh you have just vector vector
representation of actual text and you
want to retrieve the text right but but
then you you have to do some some sort
of sim similarity uh matching of that
but let's say um I find the top 10 most
relevant uh uh things you're not like in
production you're not even done yet like
there there's there's uh interesting
topics like reranking that that you
should take into account but uh let's
say you just have these Top 10
rankings you get like the initial
sentences back and enrich you the
original question so it's it's your
original question plus your top 10 list
and that goes into your language model
and then you get the answer right and
this drastically reduces hallucination
right so so this this rack technique is
is omnipresent right and I think um yeah
I I think I think it's even in the um
it's even in the uh assistant API by by
ch GPT so so they do that that
implicitly without uh really telling you
much about it okay yeah
thanks for just one quick
question thank you um great talk we try
to implement llama at a company with
only
Dutch
data how can you adapt it's like fine
tuning fine
for switching language well to be to be
honest I don't know how strong uh the
Llama models are in specific languages
right this is something you you always
have to figure out but kind of uh more
Fringe languages let's say or languages
that that are not as uh strongly
represented in in the data sets
originally used um tend to work work
worse but I think you I can only
encourage you to do your own uh
experiments with this but but
fine-tuning might definitely work in
this case right because under the
assumption that enough uh Dutch is in
the training data set you you might uh
you know massage the model into giving
you more specific uh kind of touch
answers um yeah and and something else
you you might want to check out is there
there are a lot of um kind of
initiatives to to have uh kind of these
uh no language Left Behind kind of
approaches where you have specific
models for each language and uh and I
think the open source Al alternatives
for that are getting stronger as well so
if you don't at the same time also need
some sort of domain uh specific
application or so like like a you want
to to have Dutch but also I don't know
code like python also uh then then you
might be better off with having an even
smaller model that only is is an expert
in Dutch so to speak yeah okay thank you
sure thank you uh Thanks Max uh sorry I
would love to ask more questions but uh
now is the next time for the next talk
so please uh find Max outside and also
get a copy of his book thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you